One
DayASPofLEGENDG
peoplefromAll
EnemyHISnameis
はめHISAnotherJobisOM
YouTuberHISFACEis
SPWhenheGfromhe
famouspeopleand
celebas
ashe
Aめ
[音楽]
Sこんにちははめ社長です私は普段
YouTuberとして活動しているん
ですけどももう1面別の姿がありまして
私SPってきますはい国家的に有名な機密
警察組織に所属しておりまして実はかなり
すご腕のSPとして時折りですね
YouTuberの仕事を休んで著名な方
とかセレブリティを保護しつつ目的地まで
向かったり有名な方の1日を守るというお
仕事も私はできます今回お守りするのは
日本の方日本人なんですけれどもスーパー
スペシャルハイパーセル日本でも稀に見る
少な超有名人を今回衛することになりまし
た今回ですね世界最速のプレミアジイが
あるみたいなのでそれに今回のその
セレブリティゲストを完璧に守りという1
日になると思い
ますそろそろですね到着されると思うん
ですけれども1日その方を今日守りたいと
思い
[音楽]
ますござますおはようございます到着され
ました何し
て山田孝幸さんですあSPって書いてある
はいSPですSPやるんですかよろしくお
願いします今日山田さんとても大事な
イベントがあるんですよねうんあの去年
撮影した映画の京都とかであと奈良かとか
で撮影したんですよそれで今京都にきまし
て登壇イベントだったりとかしますよ何
するのあなた大丈夫あ私今日ですね山田
孝幸さんの1日SPをさせていただきます
守ってくれるのね守って守ります今日は
守るなんかちょっと
SPのさイメージ古くないサングラスして
るっけみんないやでもやはりこう高圧的に
山田さん守りたいと思うので今日ま圧的に
ねでも他のキャストさんに迷惑かけないだ
よ分かりましたもうそこは山田さんのご
指示で私動きますのでこの感じだってでも
なんか逃走すればいいの違いますそういう
感じなんて違いますあのなのでイベント
までももちろん時間あると思いますそこ
までも山田さんに移動とか好きなことして
いただいていいんですけれども署名な方な
ので何かあってはいけないあなたも著名だ
けどねいやいや私は今日は山田のSPなの
で守ってくれるわけだ全て守ります今日は
なので好きなことしていただいて大丈夫
です好きなことてかでもなんか逃げたく
なるよこの格好してると逃げてはだめです
今日は1日よろしくお願いいたしますはい
お願いし
[音楽]
ますそれやるとね目立つのよ逆にですか
目立つ逆にですうんここいらないの別に誰
も来てないから然してます普通にこう見て
ちゃんと周りを見ててくれるばいいはい
わかりましたちょっと待って今こっち来て
初めて気づいたけどさはい
こん誰撮ってるえこれあの本部の人とあ
本部があるはいなるほどHQがあるんだ
HQあります常に連絡いただいて
じゃあタバコ吸いに行くからカメラ止めて
休んどけばあ分かりましたカメラめなさい
それいいのそれやんのあれ1日守んじゃ
ないの1日守ります上で俺変なやつにやら
れるかもしんないじゃんそうだそついて
いきますカメラありきでやってんのいや僕
はなしでもやりますそれ知っときたい本当
にマジでガッチでSPやってくれるのか
YouTubeチャンネル用としてSPの
芝居してるのかは知っときたい
今日はガチですなのでカメラ止まっても
喫煙所についていってお守りいたします
わかりましたということですねはいはい
強い
[音楽]
ですいいいいいいよもうそう嘘つないで本
本気ですよ行き
ましょうどうぞいやいやいやいやいやじゃ
運転席の後ろに乗ってほしいのよあそうな
んですね女子席の後ろが一番安全だから
そんなことも知らないのSPあそうなん
ですかうんお先に失礼します早速移動です
車ではい失礼します
はい
あれれやばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいやばい
やばいやばいやばいやばいやばい
やばいえどこ行ったどこ行った
過去この人やばい一番ごえ大変だこれ多分
山田さん突発的に走る癖があるから気を
つけないとこれ累積でしょ月か時間の累積
でもらえるんでしょあ別の番組です山田
さん山田さん普段変装とかされますよし
ないねええバレませんだ別にまだ犯罪者
じゃないから大丈夫でしょまだしてしまっ
たらねするがないよ悪いこと今日悪いこと
しても私はお守りしますのでしないよ基本
的には
[音楽]
よし神川に着きました山さんちょっと神川
で進みたいみたいなので本当ねここ一般の
方も多いので気をつけて見ていき
ましょう大丈夫
[音楽]
ですいや久
なあいるよモあ本当だ捕まえますか捕えて
くれるの
あ
ちょっとさはい1個お願いしていいはい
かしこまりましたさっき気づいたんだけど
眉毛がさ変な長いのいないここにあ1本
長くなってます抜こうとしたんだけど抜け
ないのよ抜いてもらっていいあいいですか
だってほら一応映るからあそうですよね
こっちから聞き手で失礼し
ますパっと行くはい行きますうん行けたあ
ありがとう完璧ですごめんね違う仕事やら
せ
て
やばいやばいこの人この人やばいこの人
やばい山田さん
結構奥まで来られるんです
ね
どうやっていった
の
や処理しないであい全然全く問題ないです
なんか動きづらいので来たねあいいやい
そんなそんななかなかあんなとこにいる
カメラもいないですよさすがに戻れないね
これだとねそうすねちょっとでもせっかく
の
川を楽しみたいなあそうです
[音楽]
ねあ取れ
ます大丈夫か大丈夫
リだなギリだ
[音楽]
ね
逆効果だね絶対ねやっぱね目立つもん
あなたのそこれどこでもいるおじさんいえ
山田さんはセレブリティですかセティじゃ
ないただのおじだからいやいや
おおお見てでかいえ待って何あれ濃い濃い
え食べられちゃうすごいでかいすあれさ
結構あるよいやすごいな山田さん先ほど沖
に盗撮してる人いました
おきしましょうかいいよ分かりましたど
すぎるようでしたら抹消しますので山田さ
やはりちょっとざきますねあなただと思う
いやいやいや山田高行がいるこれ歩いて
たらまずこっちに目がいであ始めちだって
それで横に誰がいるんだろうと思ったら誰
だあのおさんなんか見たことあるさっきも
あのあったの喫煙室にいたの喫煙所にそし
たらああ
山山
そんあのはめ社長でやってるじゃんずっと
その時時のさ役じゃんああそっか役の名前
が先行したりしそうですねそうそうそう
なんか売ってるよ何
[音楽]
あ手作りのすうんいい音ですねいい
あじゃあこれでありがとうございますいい
んですかはいありがとうございますはいえ
いいんですか俺
こっち
いただきました山田さんとペア熱とかない
思い出の地とか京都あすめえ危ない
かわいい来週から大型バイクの免許って
取りに行ってきますそうだね免許ないのに
買ったんだもんね免許ないのに買いました
まあなんかあれだね矢沢エキスタイルだね
それでまたどっか行くわけだ旅にちょっと
サウナ旅したいですねいいねでもバイク
あったらまたさなここに行こうカメラ
こっち向きと前とつけてさうんうんうん
色々できるじゃん車載カメラで色々取れ
そうですよね他はみんなはチーム検とか
持ってんのバイクケス取ってないですね
取らせないとみんなにバイク旅できる
じゃんみんなで取らせますか全員全員取っ
てもらった方がいい
じゃん取るかといそうだね取りますよし
言っちゃっ
たはいというわけで会場に到着しました
いよいよ山田様の本番が間近に迫っており
ますとりあえず建物の中までご案内し
ます到着しました
はいおはようございますよろしくお願いし
ます
はいしゃ
あここが控室ですねすごいねはい入ってく
んだね失礼いたしましたいい普通に入っ
ちゃいますたド素人だねやっぱねいやいや
そんな申し訳ないです普通表にいて人が
入ってくるかどうかをチェックすんだけど
ね入ってくるんだね初めまして初めまして
初です監督です監督ですよろしくお願いし
ます初め長と申しますよろしくお願いし
ますほなんか守ってくれるらしいわかりで
も僕のことだけ守るらしいはい僕は守って
もら監督はすいませんあの自己責で本日
ちょっと流れをえご説明させていただいて
え進行のえ方からえ動きですね告にさせて
いただけたらと思いますちょっと今日山高
さんSPというかちで守るために来て
いただいてはいお願いしますお願いします
願しますお願いし
ます多分敵はいないはずだからいやまだ
わからないですもう間もなく本番入ります
のでえスよ願いし願よろしくお願いします
失礼いたし
ますはいこの森には秘密が
あ2人の男は目覚めると美しく奇妙な女
たちに監禁されていた監禁されていたん
です
ねいよいよ本番です1番狙われるとすれば
ここなので気をつけていきましょう
関基本的には本当に南関のことが知らない
そ高にりますまそんな中で日本に日本全体
にです南にしロケ皆様早速ご登場いただき
ましょう大きな拍手でお迎え
[音楽]
[拍手]
ください歌う6人の女
そしてプロデューサーでもあります俳優の
さん
です何よりやっぱりその自然を壊さないっ
ていうことをみ
[音楽]
キャスは結構何度ましためちゃくちゃ
それでは者の皆様ありがとうございました
大きの拍手でおり
くださいえ皆様にこの後ご覧いただきます
竹の内と山中孝行きのダブルダブ主演に
よるスまたトーもありますので移動し
ましょう到着しました大丈夫はいいない
今回は野外っぽいのでちょっと狙撃とか
怖いですね高台ちゃんと見といて
かしこまりまし
[音楽]
たえっといやいやこちらで私
ははい先ほどの反をしてですね控室の前で
こう待機しますSP用の控室もあります
[音楽]
ねモールス信号を送り
ます
せあすいませ失礼いたしましたうせすせ
失礼いたしましたチェックしてくれてんの
なんかはいあの壁と壁の間に爆破物がない
かなと思いましてトントとトントン
トントンの必要はないよねそうですね失礼
いたしましたご
ゆっくり一応ね俺の控室もありますけど何
が来ても危なくないように結構見ながら
ここで待機しますちょっと覗いてみようか
[音楽]
じゃ
はい何か危ないくないかなと思って一応
確認今悪いことしてた悪いことしてたん
ですうんちょっとハンバーが食べたあそ
全然たくさん食べて
ください鍵かけたえ次すごいよ青い山田
さん来るやばすごいね豪華
[音楽]
す酒があるねあ違う守りがあるね疲れた
なSPも大変だね皆様え順番一斉に
ステージにえ登場していただきます一応
あの山田さんのSPでやてくれてますので
あのよろしくお願いしすいませんよろしく
お願いします行き
ましょう
トイレは集いになります
はい次の現場きまし
たえ次は野外なのでそうですねは豊かです
トンボがたくさんい
ますいい景色ですね危険そうな人はいませ
ん
ね見るからに危険そうな人っての方が
少ないからね本当ですか確かにそういう人
は紛れますからね普通の人
に
誰けてないよ
あの結構何も聞こえなくなっちゃって
いやいや何も聞こえない指示をそうそう
ですそうですそうですびっくりした何何
言ってんの
俺分かりました本当に本部あるあり
ますアメリカのロサンゼルスに本部があり
まして
ええずっと衛星で見られて
ます山田さんの
動き心拍見てくれてる見てます全て
ありがとう
[音楽]
はいそうです
ねあ
お会いできて嬉しいとあったよねあ無事を
祈ると本部から祈っちゃだめでしょ守るあ
はいあなた方が守ってあそうです守ります
祈ら
ないごめんと言っますどうぞお願いします
お気をつけて行ってらっしゃい
[音楽]
ませ
ダブル主演そして共同プロデューサーでも
あります俳優の山田さん
ですいろんな全国のその森を歩いてご自分
のイメージのあるとこ探していたというっ
たんですがはいそうですねあのシナリオ
始めたの5年前
でそれからんですけどやっぱりもう
1度に撮影してのがあれ
ば映画を通して伝えるためにちょっとそう
いうことやるねってまそことやりまくって
撮影そのが終わったらまたり
[拍手]
ます
[音楽]
願
本日最後に皆様お越しいただきました皆様
の写真撮影のお時間とさせていただきます
記念写真撮影とかだと会場のボルテージが
一気に上がるの
で結構僕危ないと思ってますお願い
[音楽]
ます丈でしょうかでは皆さ写真撮影
ありがとうございましたい人がいる楽しん
でくださいありがとうございました
ありがとうございましたでは皆様大きな
拍手でお送りくださいありがとうござい
まし
た
[音楽]
はいというわけで山田さん1日お疲れ様
でしたお疲れ様でしたお疲れ様でし
たどうでしたかウジ
いやあ
まあ何もなかったですただ何もなかったの
が一番良いことでもあると思うのではい
特にあのすることもなくずっと守ってたん
ですけどもうんうんうんあのま個人的には
山田さんと1日入れてすごい楽しかった
です山田さん僕もです山田さんすいません
ちょっと今撮影
[音楽]
です
ちょ大丈夫ですか丈夫夫なんで先なんでさ
何も行ってくれなかったい僕山さんのまで
ってきたですありがとうありがとううい
ですね今ちょっとごめんまだまだ撮影し
てんの今ごめんねごめんごめん僕島根から
来たんですよ
山夫島根から来たんですね
ち1回そうはいちょっと山田さんも
ちょっと困っちゃうのでき
ましじゃはいじゃお入れはい大丈夫ですか
はいということで
ねはいじゃあご苦労さでし
た良かったね何もなくてねえ誰ですか俳優
の増田です
田
[音楽]
ですマジですかいついつ気づいてたこの人
いやもう最初からずっといるなと思ってた
んですけどちょっと待って今こっち来て
初めて気づいたけど
さっ
てす山田さん
とあああどう
でしょう
ゲルっていうのはいろんな意味があるん
ですけどこの曲では自然の声っていう風に
っその自然の声を私たち人間たがちゃんと
み
てこんな風に思ったいやでも山田さん多分
男性にも人気あるからこういうファンも
いるなと思ってたんすけどうんちょっと
怖かったいやめっちゃ怖かったすよ
めっちゃ怖かったすよかった知ってた知ら
なかったすちょっと待って怖かったもう
ステージの時も登る勢いだったんで
メディアゾーンにいたじゃないですかもう
結構ね俺どうしようって言ってたもんね
いやそこだからSPだから来るかなと思っ
たけど全然来ないからいやいやいや
ステージ登ってたらマジで行ってましたで
も本当さすがにそこまではねちょさすがに
そうですねやっぱイベント壊すことだけが
一番まずいと思ったのでうん壊されたら僕
も壊しに行ってましたまでも良かった
怖かったのねいや怖怖かって良かった
ですそうだったんすねちょっとぐらい
やっぱさドキドキさせたいなと思って久々
に会うからさあそうだったんですねなんか
触れていいものかもわかんなくてガチ
ファンだったらねそのほらリアルだった
でしょえそうなんですよ馬鹿にもできない
じゃないですか今行けたねでもね最後は
っといやもう山田さんの一定距離まで来る
と行こうって心の準備はしてたんでいう
かっこいいはいさすが最後守れてよかった
ですけどうんめっちゃ怖いっすねこの
人この人は怖くないあこの人は怖くない
ですかこう焼くとしてあ良かったねも本当
にあるかもしれないのでねドキドキしたね
ドキドキできたねドできましたよかった
よかったありがとうございますあれ
ドッキリ